oh hey didn't see you there spider-man 4
toby maguire sam raimi it's a headline
that will completely blow your mind if
you're a fan of the web head
now a new report from comicbookmovie.com
has just dropped stating that this film
could be in the works
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the new story whether
we think it's true or not and what i've
heard behind the scenes to discuss if
this has
any viability or not if this is your
first time here welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
i do videos that are a lot better than
this normally much better produced
but with this just being a news report i
thought i'd just go through it and read
it out because let's face it it's the
easter holidays and who else can be
bothered with that i know you can't and
that's why you're here
now the article starts off with sony
reportedly wants sam raimi and toby
maguire to reunite for spider-man 4.
wow what a headline however the next
paragraph down
kinda gives you an inkling of exactly
what's going on
it says we're approaching hard to
believe territory with this one
but a new report is seemingly suggesting
that sony pictures is keen to reunite
director sam raimi with toby maguire for
a spider-man 4
question mark never put question marks
in statements
now this is something i've actually
heard going on behind the scenes and
apparently from my source dude bro trust
me
when marvel studios were renegotiating
tom holland's contract with sony
sony not only said they wanted their
universe to basically collide with the
mcu
but they also stated that they want to
be able to go off and make their own
spider-man projects featuring characters
like
well not characters but actors like toby
maguire and andrew garfield now their
introduction is apparently in spider-man
no way home
that's kind of going back and forth with
there being
a lot of studio denial at the moment but
i personally believe that it's happening
and this will sort of open the door to
the multiverse and
allow these actors to come back and
finish on these projects
now sam raimi was a big get for in the
multiverse of madness
and apparently kevin feige wanted to get
him because he'd help getting toby
maguire
which would then create this whole
multiverse thing that they could just
make billions and billions of dollars
from
now the report goes on to say in rumor
mill we share the hard to buy rumors
so yeah sounds sounds like they're
really confident that don't come from
reliable sources like the trades
but are still more believable just than
what you might find on reddit
so yeah kind of kind of seems like
they're they're sort of playing the hand
a bit
now as the wait for spider-man no way
home which has been rumored to feature
an appearance by toby mcguire
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which sam raimi is in the
director's chair intensifies
the rumor mill has never been hotter has
been hotter because
once my mate sharon said that billy
jenkins finger
behind the bike [ __ ] at school and that
was a that was a pretty hot rumor at the
time i remember that
now the latest report is a potential
bombshell that could reshape the entire
future of this spider-verse now
sony are very keen to move forward with
this spider-verse
i though tom holland sort of falls under
the mcu umbrella
they clearly have a lot of plans for
things if they're green lighting a
madame web movie
which yeah if they're green lighting
that then they'll probably green light
spider-man 4. now
spider-man 4 was a film that sort of
went through production hell
it was originally meant to be made um i
think it was featuring the lizard but i
haven't looked i haven't looked up it
for for quite a while and i can imagine
that if they do go forward with the
lizard featuring an amazing spider-man
one
that they would completely scrap that
and start fresh obviously toby maguire
is a lot older now as well
so i could kind of see them potentially
tying in with
no way home and then going off and doing
their own thing
now as i've said i have heard this rumor
has a lot of weight to it which is why
i'm
i'm reporting on it and it just makes a
lot of sense business-wise you don't
bring toby mcguire
back just for a cameo and set him up as
spider-man to then
mothball it and say well we're turning
down all this free cash that we'd make
from spider-man 4.
sam raimi is obviously very very keen to
get back into doing superhero movies
otherwise he wouldn't have returned for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
so whether this is true or not i can see
why this rumor is starting to pick up
steam as there are a lot of things that
make a lot of sense
and yeah it just it just all lines up
now like always
take this with a huge grain of salt
which is one of my catchphrases so
thanks for putting that in the article
maybe even a whole box of it oh no what
but giant freaking robot who have had a
few scoops out in the past
is reporting that sony picked they've
had a few scoops
some poop some scoops anyway they've
been
they've expressed interest in bringing
back both raymond mcguire for a
potential fourth entry in the spider-man
series
i'm actually gonna go to giant freaking
robot and see exactly what they're
saying
as this is this is quite a big rumor and
uh
you you need to you need to have your
sources lined up here
okay so we're at the source part of the
article now according to one of our
trusted
and proven inside sources called dude
bro trust me trust me bro
sony wants toby mcguire and sam raimi to
reunite for another spider-man movie so
the source that they've listed can i
trust them
no um says it's proven well i don't know
that
could be anyone so again take it with a
pinch of salt a grain of salt as it says
and the article goes on to say you have
the presence of an adult spider-man
would affect the future of both marvel
studios and sony's plans is also unclear
but it could open the door for one
spider-man in the mcu
and one in the sumc potentially setting
the stage for showdowns with venom
morbius and others and this kind of
calls back to mobius and you might
remember in the trailer for that there
was a spider-man poster
which had the word murderer written
across it now a lot of people are
confused as it was the sam raimi suit
from the ps4 spider-man game
and we and we were just like maybe they
don't have the rights to tom holland and
maybe this is just a cool little easter
egg now the reason that i actually
heard they did that is because the
mobius film is gonna
sort of be in the the toby mcguire
universe where the snap hasn't happened
and so on
and that is exactly why they use that
artwork now whether that's the truth or
not
we don't know but bear in mind michael
keaton
was in that trailer and he of course
played the vulture
so i kind of feel like they're leaving
the door open to explore possible other
avenues
but they haven't nailed down things a
hundred percent
bear in mind toby mcguire hasn't even
been confirmed at the moment is
appearing in no way home
so whether we know this to be true or
not
i don't know personally from what i've
heard i think he is going to be in that
film and then i think he will pop up in
doctor strange too and that'll kind of
open the doors but
for the moment i'd imagine that the
studio are very much
keeping their their cards close to their
chest they're spying on the web
and seeing what rumors swing through the
mill
to see what the audience reaction is to
these crap puns
now personally i think that this entire
thing will have been discussed by sony
at least at some point
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to think that
this hasn't even crossed the minds of
people in the studio
especially when they're focused on
making money and they've clearly got
huge plans for spider-man going forward
because
at the moment he's sony's biggest
property i think far from home was their
first ever movie to cross the
1 billion mark so for them to be green
lighting things like
you know madame webb as i've said it
just seems like this would be such a
no-brainer
and i can see them moving forward with
it now this report still a bit skeptical
on it
i would wait until we find out about
toby mcguire being in the film before we
put too much faith into this
but i just thought i'd report on it as
it is quite a big story now if i had to
give it a score out of 100 with a
hundred being
this is definitely happening and zero
being no way mate
no way then i would probably score
at 65. i think it will have been
discussed at some point but
i doubt very much that toby would have
signed on to do multiple films
i think what's been happening behind the
scenes is that they're kind of working
out the contract for this initial movie
and perhaps doctor strange too
and then from there they're going to
look at whether they can bring them back
in a successful way whether the fans
want it
and exactly how easy this is going to be
to make because
this could be a massive massive film for
sony and the best thing about it for
them is that they wouldn't have to share
revenue with marvel studios
unless of course they worked out clauses
in their contract to say well we'll set
up this universe
and you give us like 10 back of the
money because you know these these
business men and these lawyers
they need matt murdock involved for that
hey who is in spiderman no way home and
you can bank on that
anyway obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts below sorry this is just kind
of a
very basic video um i'm working on
invincible at the moment for
friday and i'm also getting things
prepared for falcon in the winter
soldier so
just kind of rushing through this but i
hope you enjoy this more personal talk
towards the camera
subscribe buttons there like buttons
there dislike buttons there too but
don't
don't press that and yeah i'll see you
next time if you want something else to
watch we've got loads of breakdowns on
at the moment including one on who the
power broker might be
king kong easter eggs and a lot more so
yeah definitely check them out after
this
i mean paul take care